هذا اجتمعت علينا اثار الكوبيد مع الحرب
الاوكرانيه مع الجفاف الذي يعيشه الوطن
منذ سبعه اشهر تقريبا وهذا ادى الى رحاله
المواد الاساسيه في البلد والى عدم توفر
السيول الماليه التي تمكننا من ان ننزل
على السوق العالميه لنقتني حاجياتنا وهذا
خطر كبير احذر ابناء وطني من ان يتناسبوه
ولا يشعروا به وكل ذلك
بين تونس في كل المشاهد على المستوى
السياسي على المستوى حتى الاجتماع على كل
المستويات بالتالي لا مخرج همم اليوم ربما
كما يرى البعض من هذه الحاله في تونس في
ظل هذه الحاله من سداد الافق السياسي اولا
الذي يمكن ان يصلح بعض الامور الاقتصاديه
اذا نجحت
انا في تصوري ان التوجه ينبغي ان ينصب على
الواقع الاجتماعي والاقتصادي بشكل اساسي
لان الجانب السياسي يمكن ان ينتظر لا يمكن
ان نتخاصم سياسيا ونحن جوعه لا يمكن ان
نتخاصم سياسيا وجزء من ابناء وطننا لا
يجدون الحاجيات الاساسيه الشعب لا يهم
الخلاف السياسي الشعب الذي يهمه
ان يشجع على الانتاج على العمل على
التنميه ينبغي ان تتوفر لدينا الامكانيات
التي من خلالها نصنع الثروه من جديد صعب
هذا سبيل ولكن هو السبيل الذي يمكن ان
ينقذنا وان نترك جانبا تلك الخلافات
السياسيه التي تعصب بكياناتنا والتي
تلهينا عن الاهم وهو توفيره مناعه ان
شعبنا حتى لا يحتاج في طعامه ولباسه
ودوائه وفي تربيه ابناءه